le directeur général de la santé didier
houssin a elle invité et de ce journal
vous êtes aussi délégué interministériel
à la lutte contre la grippe aviaire
bonsoir pour soi alors cet appel aux
nations unies inquiète forcément quel
est l'état réel de la menace aujourd'hui
à la menace est importante
c'est une menace très importante pour
l'espèce humaine du type des grands
conflits mondiaux
c'est à dire qu'on est dans un phénomène
qui pourrait rappeler la peste d'il ya
quelques centaines d'années où le
choléra ou la grippe espagnole de
1918-1919 ça veut dire des millions de
malades et probablement des millions de
décès donc le problème n'est pas de
savoir s'il y aura une épidémie mais
quand elle aura lieu c'est ça peut être
très bientôt
voilà c'est le moment de le fait qu'une
épidémie surviennent et probablement une
grippe très grave est quasiment une
certitude ce qui est en revanche moins
certains c'est le moment précis où ça va
survenir
la seule chose que nous savons c'est que
depuis quelques mois depuis le début de
l'année 2004 il ya des signes qui
laissent penser que ce moment pourrait
s'être rapproché et donc il faut se
préparer les signes c'est quoi par
exemple les signes c'est à dire qu'un
virus a est apparu chez le ch et le
poulet qui est capable de tuer un grand
nombre de poulets capable de se
transmettre à l'homme
et quand il survient chez l'homme de
entraîné le décès assez souvent alors là
on a vu qu'en allemagne les volailles
vont rester enfermés que les suisses
surveillent leur d'oiseaux migrateurs
que les américains renforcent la
surveillance de toutes formes de grippe
est ce que cela est vraiment utile et en
france de l'autre côté qu'est ce qu'on
fait fois que les mesures et elles sont
aujourd'hui de 2 2 deux catégories pour
ce qui est d'essayer d'éviter l'épidémie
de devenir en france c'est premièrement
de d'essayer de faire en sorte que des
personnes contaminées et bien neuneu
propres ne parviennent pas trop
rapidement sur le territoire français et
puis de faire en sorte aussi que les
voilà les volailles les animaux
domestiques et bien ne soit pas
contaminée de la manière qui a été dit
dans le reportage est laissée comme en
allemagne les oies les volailles enfermé
c'est utile aujourd'hui les experts
européens et français ont estimé que
cela n'était pas une précaution
indispensable dans l'état actuel de la
situation
est ce qu'on n'en fait pas trop et ce
qu'on d'impact trop loin dans le
principe de précaution quand même mais
je crois que dans une situation de ce
type où on a malgré tout un sentiment
d'urgence le principe de précaution
c'est de prendre des précautions
maximales est effectivement aujourd'hui
je crois que la responsabilité des pays
c'est de protéger au maximum leur
population d'aider aussi un jour les
pays qui ont les moyens ne pourront pas
être rassemblé et c'est ce que fait la
france
déjà depuis de nombreux mois et
continuera à se préparer encore
davantage visitez dès les pays moins
développés ça veut dire qu'en cas de
grippe aviaire les pays développés
auraient plus de chances de s'en sortir
que les pays c'est le sens du message du
premier ministère qu'il s'agit essayer
de constituer également une capacité
d'action au niveau du pays sources pour
essayer d'ailleurs de limiter le risque
de d'épidémie y compris chez les chez
les oiseaux et en même temps d'essayer
d'aider aussi ces pays à défendre leur
population parce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est qu'il n'y aura pas de
vraie vaccin avant l'arrivée de se faire
de ce virus s'est passé pas possible
combien de temps il faudra pour le
trouver une fois que le vaccin avec le
virus sera arrivé entre le moment où le
virus responsable d'une épidémie grave
très isolé et le moment où on pourra
commencer à produire des vaccins il va
se s'écouler environ six mois
mais durant ces périodes de six mois
nous ne serons pas démuni puisqu'il y
aura des médicaments qui existe et que
plusieurs pays achète et dont la france
en grande quantité qui eux sont capables
également de traiter la maladie
et puis à le port du masque qui sera une
précaution certaines très importante
merci professeur où ça me rappelle
simplement qu'il ya eu trois grandes
grippe en 20e siècle celle de 1918 19
entre 20 et 100 millions de morts et
puis la grippe de hong kong également en
58 et en 67 entre 4 et 10 millions de
morts merci merci beaucoup